hop
[Musique]
oui
ouais
[Musique]
vous voici arrivé à l'as rome au terme
d'une carrière exemple
entrée salut lafarge salut alors ça
s'est bien passé
oui
- versa et les jumelles
il y avait quelques angles
oui lanning je rentre vite qu'abriel
dois m'attendre en ce brin de séjour un
ballon pas demain matin je passerai
quand même te dire bonjour
[Musique]
aux heures sombres de l'occupation où
vous avez participé aux combats
quotidiens de résistance faire
maintenant que vous allez prendre une
retraite bien méritée entouré de ceux
qui vous sont chers la femme des enfants
ou qui nous vous disons au revoir à
lafarge au revoir et merci
geci furieuse
j'ai voulu de préparer un bon dîner
qu'est ce que j'ai fait je suis coupé en
avoir les huîtres montre jamais de
l'alcool oui tu serais arrivé seulement
cinq minutes plus tard mais tout est en
règle
bref je peux repartir si dieu veut jolie
table je mets ta ville rose n'est pas un
soir comme les autres
ça me fait encore mal ta main
non c'est fini elles sont bonnes c'était
comment bureau comme d'habitude la niña
fin le petit laïus de rigueur mais cette
fois-ci témoin le héros le fait c'est
gentil les jumelles très gentil c'est un
joli souvenir
à souvenirs oui
bonjour tu déjà debout j'avais demandé
dans le plateau j'avais envie de prendre
mon petit déjeuner avec toi j'ai une
réunion la ligue aujourd'hui avec moi
j'en ai parlé voyons me suis inscrite à
musique les consommateurs ah oui la
nouvelle lubie
or c'est pas une lubie les consommateurs
doivent s'aligner pour se défendre quand
on voit ce que nous fait manger
tiens regarde composition farine sel
malte lactosérum émulsifiants et 322 e
471 antioxydants et 300 je veux du
saccharose dans ta dilution caféine
regardez
tu es habillée comme quoi le bureau
c'est vrai comment s'habiller emprunter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors monsieur lafarge
vous êtes un large front oui madame
rochette
ça va vous faire trop d'être à la maison
toute la journée c'est pas encore c'est
le premier jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
alors c'est la fin
il paraît que vous êtes atteint la
limite d'âge on le dit oui mais j'ai
encore du temps mis quatre mois à tirer
soyez pas trop pressé après on regrette
vous avez raison ça va faire une bonne
impression d'échec pas toute la journée
à l'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
qu'est ce que tu fais
[Musique]
quoi
j'y serai les valeurs diop avec rémy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici la gare de blé en yvelines c'est
une gare de banlieue
le dernier train de voyageurs passent à
22h23 après son départ le chef de gare
c'est faux les portes à clé et dans les
lumières
la gare est fermée jusqu'au lendemain
matin vous arriverez à 22h32 président
vous ne passerez pas par les garder
parce portillon aussitôt que vous
l'aurez franchissement fille de raymond
cagoulés vos plantes
vous attendrez ici derrière le poste
d'aiguillage que les voyageurs du
dernier track quitte sa gare faux patrie
alors sur le quai voici le chebeya
habituellement il semble après avoir
fermé la gare à clé mais ce soir là il
sera de garde
s'il se tiendra dans son bureau
[Musique]
pour vous en parler de lui vous lui
attacher les mains et les pieds
pour le transporter et dans le bureau de
l'agent l'exploitation
et là que se trouve le téléphone de
services vous serez alors mètres de la
gare veuillez vous approchez de la
raquette
[Musique]
et
à 3 heures 45 dans la nuit du 29 au 30
mai un brin de marchandises doit
traverser la gare s'enfuit avec les mets
trois minutes avant son passage une
voiture s'engagera dans le passage à
niveau
elle qui arrêtera et prendra feu le
signal se fermera le métayer arrêtera sa
machine à hauteur du second qui se
couche juste avant le signal venir
gagner vos places
[Musique]
et
la banque de france retire régulièrement
de la circulation les billets usés une
fois par an ils sont envoyés en province
pour y être brûlés le deuxième wagon
contiendra 7 milliards d'anciens francs
en billets du decs bon de celui payé de
factures et aussitôt que le train sera
arrêté vous décrocherez les attelages
pour y donner le deuxième wagon
voici un hélicoptère une idée dans
l'armée américaine pour enlever les
chats endommagé dans les zones de combat
un appareil du même type sera utilisé
pour notre opération 50 secondes
exactement après l'arrêt du train ils
s'immobilisera au dessus de la gare et
déroulera son prix vous accrocherez le
mât conflit vous embarquerez à bord de
l'hélicoptère
vous allez maintenant pouvoir poser des
questions veuillez lobby la main et
attendre pour parler le signal vers
votre allumé
[Musique]
on sera combien dans la guerre cinq
messieurs nature
on sera armé d'un authentique
les autres n'auront pas d'armes mais
pourquoi pour éviter tout risque
d'accident
[Musique]
on doit arriver à 22h32 pourquoi si tout
pour ne pas attirer l'attention après la
fermeture de la gare
il n'y aura personne dans les rues
autrement dit on passera toute la nuit
dans la gare
oui vous aurez des rideaux noirs pour
occulter les fenêtres qu'est ce qu'on
fait si quelqu'un vient la gare est
surveillé en permanence depuis trois
mois
personne ni entre jamais la nuit on aura
une liaison radio avec vous mais que
l'on à un numéro de téléphone pour me
joindre en cas d'urgence on va marquer
[Musique]
la banque de france oblitère les billets
par perforation du mot annulé
on les introduit par piles de 200 dans
une machine équipée de poing sont les
mâchoires se resserre et les poinçons
s'enfonce dans les billets pour s'en
servir
la plupart des billets seront d'un tacle
les poinçons sont fixés par des mandrins
si les mandrins sont altérées les
poinçons obligataires les premiers et
les derniers de chaque pile
ensuite ils rentrent dans leur gorge à
l'intérieur des mâchoires
les surveillants verront que les
premiers et les derniers sont perforés
une seule personne peut s'apercevoir
qu'il se passe quelque chose d'anormal
elle employait qui manoeuvrent la presse
et il ne va rien aux la direction de la
banque bien monory de sa confiance
[Musique]
le wagon n'est pas blindé non il y aura
trente deux convoyeurs
ils resteront dans le wagon on ne les
buts rapport et retenant compris
veuillez répéter je veux dire on ne les
tuera pas donc il totalement neutralisée
pendant quelques heures en bas je trouve
pas ça très brûlot payer réfléchir avant
de parler il tient debout n'a de casier
judiciaire
la police ne possède pas vos empreintes
digitales on ne pourra pas vous
identifier vous avez tout prévu
oui qui organise des cours moi dit c'est
moi et donc non recevable personne ne
sera tué il n'y aura pas de temps à
perdre et je suis bon
[Musique]
avez vous d'autres questions à poser
veuillez vous présenter ici demain et
les jours suivants à 10 heures et à 16
heures aux instructions ou seront
répétés jusqu'à ce que vous les
connaissiez parfaitement deux séances
[Musique]
barba
désiré
tu es là tu sais la nouvelle il va en
nommer vice président de la cellule je
veux le politique maintenant non la
cellule locale de la ligue
ah bon c'est fait pas plaisir
si très plaisir dis donc j'ai pensé pour
notre anniversaire de mariage la semaine
prochaine pour inviter les enfants dîner
on ça a été une bonne idée
c'est moi qui m'occupe du repas pourquoi
je peux le faire non non ça m'amuse et
puis j'ai le temps et seulement des rémy
devenir aussi c'est que je ne peux pas
je suis des bardes de garde
la faculté tellement 4878 circulera nuit
du 29 au 30 est assurée surveillance
spéciale de la gare c'est président la
république qu'il fasse j'en sais rien ne
donne pas d'explication
c'est bête compter sur toi
aux trente ans de mariage faire alice
elle est par valérie hains maison bien
sûr fait pas laisser seul nom de kim de
l'histoire ainsi que nos voisins crossed
bon qu'on voulait pas mais c'est pas bon
d'être un mauvais soir mais j'étais ne
restez pas là vous disant salut les
copains grâce à roger lendemain il est
en toi en référence comme tarbes du
perche derrière toi tv monsieur et
madame lafarge ne serait ce pas ce soir
votre anniversaire de mariage
aujourd'hui gens me parlent et je sais
ce que tu vas me dis à mon regard tu
vois tout ce que je désire
pourquoi demander aux autres un roman
l'émerveillement comme la nôtre non
existent la haute forme de la santé
grand mère ils vont les vendre des
gâteaux
c'est rare avec plaisir attention à ton
estomac se fait
quoi de neuf à la statistique gérard
beaucoup de boulot avec l'analyse du
dernier recensement quoi c'est pas
encore finit bien pour plusieurs années
en somme les recensements ont surtout
pour but de donner du travail aux aussat
titi tient aux statisticiens
mais non c'est très important les
statistiques ça permet de connaître le
clivage la population et de déterminer
les besoins réels des consommateurs par
catégorie socioprofessionnelle
tu peux pas parler français comme tout
le monde - qu'est-ce que c'est le
clivage de la population mes enfants
j'ai une grande nouvelle à vous annoncer
maman a été élu vice président de la
cellule non on fait de la politique de
la cellule locale d'une ligue de
consommateurs donc c'est pas un peu
dingue non pas noël tu parles à ta mère
mais je suis pas du tout avec la vie
qu'on mène la façon dont on est soumis
aux lois la publicité d'ailleurs tout un
médecin eh ben tu devrais savoir lui
médecin est en deuxième année de
médecine
et encore elle a failli se faire est en
toi ça va il fera bien content de me
trouver plus tard pour se soigner tes
techland tu fais une gifle ça il fait la
blague qu'il fallait geler sa grande
soeur écoutez moi ça la mère de mes
enfants
enfin valérie mois à votre place beau
papa à gérard vous feriez un genre très
acceptable si vous perdiez cette manie
de m'appeler toujours beau peuple qui
veut un cigare d'un gâteau merci j'en
peux plus passer la part de rémy je vais
là lui apporter maintenant j'en ai pour
cinq minutes je peux tu as menée en
bagnole si tu veux non non je vais en
profiter pour sortir livre
elle n'est pas dans son bureau au mans
il n'est pas dans son bureau
allez allons là-bas fia non non non
c'est vrai mais ça c'est pas pour toi
tient tous pour l'isolation prise
coucou c'est moi
qu'est ce que vous foutez là d'avoir à
me renier brochage chef des verts michel
aulas la visite y avoir saisie gars côté
c'est un ami je l'avais invité pour
fêter mon train de vie ou là qu'est ce
qu'on fait qu'est ce que tu veux qu'on
fasse en faire mieux avec l'autre allez
messieurs je ne comprends pas les gros
et je voudrais savoir et minutes
car ça ne vous attend non pas de femme
pas d'enfant
je ne suis pas marié vit seul et
contient tellement mario et ça c'est pas
une alliance
je suis veuf bon genre tu resteras vécu
à l'est ok ça lui rémy chez toi lafarge
oui ça va qu'est ce que ça veut dire
tout ça je pense qu'il faut de quoi rire
je ne comprends pas à les rendre et là
aussi oui c'est vrai c'est moi de faire
mal si je vois ça je te porter un
morceau de gâteau un mot pour mieux au
fait comment très bien très bien ça
s'est très bien passé je m'ennuyais tout
seul à la maison alors je suis dit oh
bonjour j'étais tout seul la maison
comprend qu'on prend
et le bon ton bientôt mais attention au
mille club est ce que cessent les phones
téléphones service
répondez faites gaffe à séoul
alors assez toi le grand bé oui elle
tout va bien non non non non je ne suis
pas seul nom et il ya lafarge qui est
venu rendre une petite visite et c'est
ça oui oui c'est ça on se rappellera
plus tard
enfin lafarge
si vous ils vous connaissent de la
boutique vous aussi oui enfin le nom je
suis retraité tu vas t'emmerder seul
chez toi toute la journée l'élan
abonnement qu'est-ce qui fabrique la
voir avec rami par dix ce qui va revenir
bah pas voulu aller chercher un nom
patois trois bonshommes ensemble vous
allez passer toute la nuit
j'y vais moi tu me passes et que les
aventures c'est pas loin depuis elle à
pied
je sais conduire tu sais hélas garrison
affirmé tu passes par les par la petite
porte à droite tu connais
[Musique]
papa ennemis ou jouent papa et au robin
personne n'attendait un [ __ ] tu a
interdit un meilleur ça n'a quand même
désordre à présent étoiles alors le père
la fille l'après qui m'afflige un grand
mère le petit cousin personnes qui
étaient venus dîner avec moi pourquoi tu
as dis tu étais seul un sens fiancée
parce que lui aussi leur appliquer non
il fait son service militaire
bon alors vous la maladie reste avec moi
bon comme vous voulez a plus ou moins
deux mois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
en visite à cuba du dentier temps
d'appeler ça dansait au fond ça va mais
si la brique ça fait vingt minutes
claudine est parfait la gamme dont j'ai
une idée si on y allait nous aussi el
haggar ripper ont fini la soirée des
crèches fondu à y comprendre le chanvre
indien la musique
[Musique]
y a pas de lumière
abba peut-être qui roupille entend
réveiller des gens qui dorment dans le
quartier de bourg la danse et leurs eaux
montent atteint david et qui sait on est
une surprise pour vous ah ben c'est pas
trop tôt
bonjour garage je suis là gabriel n'ai
pas peur continue à faire le guet peut
aussi qu'à vous autres passés par ici
aligné vous retenir goût de réchauffé la
ficelle le chien fait le terme air va le
chercher
j'ai trouvé ça a tâché de jeunes les
pieds les mains vous sautera si couche
toi là elle s'était pas le challenge il
règle son compte
tiens tu peux de l'autre gauche pratique
ça y est ramenez vous décidez pas le
faire les marioles c'est compris ça va
les enfants aux biens très très bien je
mens soirée d'hier et qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire mais rien du tout voyons tu
crois qu'ils vont me tuer non
si j'avais voulu nous tuer alors il fait
tout de suite lorsqu'il faut c'est très
calme très calme pour leur montrer qu
n'ont pas peur si la dire vous allez la
move et wii
eh bien à surveiller bersani bien gérer
la ligne essam el hassan sahal ap
l'organisation qui était prévu on peut
pas tout prévoir
c'est un coup comme ça si bon il faut
quelqu'un je savais que pour les
surveiller qui commence il en est à
kaboul pour quoi faire
le but est là puis nous aurons lui
semble mais c'est vrai ça c'est bien ce
que je disais connaissent nos gueules
folle et décembre
on n'a pas le choix tu as entendu les
instructions pas de sang pas envie
qu'ils allaient passer chez les flics en
un contrat qu'on ressemble il ya de la
place dans l'hélico on va laisser
embarquer avec nous enfin comme les
convoyeurs
il ya d'autres équipes mais comme il a
dit neutraliseront pendant quelques
heures le temps qu'on se rassure de
france après sa maman si vous voulez
monter en moi je m'en charge de trouver
ça jamais on avait dit pas d'âme oui
j'ai pas dû entendre
moi c'est à maurice qui cherchait toile
bouche portman vous êtes un pourquoi oui
ce range ton jouet je veux plus voir
compris
le jeune dirigeant
rester assis
écoutez c'est absurde tout ça nous avons
rien fait le bordeaux
et je te remplace ou
diffusion n'en reste aucun si ce
parterre
comme ça pas de foot
mon fils était étudiant en médecine
bonfi de chroniques mon ami vous fumez
tron à ce rythme là vous fera part du
gaz au toit non plus ah si tu continues
sur ce ton oh purée de mangue ardente
marrant
soula bien regarder je me demande
pourquoi vous êtes venez vous enfermer
dans cette gare quand même le yom
peut-être qu'on a envie de prendre le
train pour risquez d'attendre le premier
des six heures ont fait peur on se
reporte eu à vos réunions on prend le
train de 3h47 gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la dame de coeur ne veut pas laisser de
casa 3
electric a perdu cela voilà vous avez
compris
vous aimez les chiens oui
je me doute
est ce que c'est un acte profane oui
j'ai apporté avec rohff et alors et la
tendance baissière du champagne futenma
au les mêmes que des cigares des 10
on va mettre un peu de musique ce sera
plus gai ya andré double champion mais
c'est du monde
oui
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce que vous combien ces
messieurs dames nous invite à les
habituer mais pas les habitants sont ici
[Musique]
j'ai tombé sous laquelle tous les cas
les civils pour cent
oreilles quand tu lis on ne rigole pas
heureusement que c'est pas tout et dubai
est l'adresse d'un merci elle est sur le
registre de mon bureau
tu veux que je te la donne a tant dit
que vous rappellerez dans cinq minutes
je te rapelle en cinq minutes
d'accord votre copain tu sais où ils
elles régissent vrais gens va chercher
dès qu'il aura téléphoner en l'enfermant
avec les autres ce sera plus facile pour
les garder ça y est il à rappeler
il a donné l'adresse rien j'ai trouvé
pas des registres villon samoa joli
projet jouer quand j'étais gosse ça et
on fait une partie de culte au jeu
oublié comment ils jouent moi aussi
cette fois moins 15 ans avait pas de
règles déjà sa venue jouer ou alors
montrez nous
[Applaudissements]
quelqu'un doit tenir la banque qui
veulent trop dangereux par les temps qui
courent et vous qui allez venir la
banque
je vous distribue 150 mille francs à
chacun ses poids lourds
c'est la règle du jeu pour vous en
procurer davantage pendant la partie
dites les gars vous rend les ventes de
bons joueurs avec des vrais tirer pour
savoir qui commence la chaîne
[Musique]
2000 enfants à vous tirer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben quoi c'est sur la case est en prison
suite au choc
vous ne recevrez pas aller là mille
francs de la case départ
vous pouvez pas percevoir de loyaux ni
vendre ni acheter ni pratique et
gaffière label les sortir de prison
qu'en payant une amende de 5000 francs
bon bah je vais payer
pas dans le prochain tour à vous
[Musique]
suspense
un monde pourri 2010
[Musique]
tiens gare saint lazare au yoga vous
achetez trop bien ses amis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1 2 3 4 paradis ouais ben j'ai passé mon
fou de murs de thoune bon alors qu'est
ce qu'il boit de 50 mille balles à 20%
charrier la banque pour acheter une
propriété
[Musique]
tiens al capone
mais ça fait un bout sur le redis valu à
la part dont vous êtes obligés de payer
j'ai dit je paye pas si vous commencez à
tricher
[Applaudissements]
test communauté aller en prison
mais j'en ai marre de ce choix là
[Musique]
vous voyez bien que ce prix nous le
savika tout le fric il nous a plu mais
vous n'y avez pas comme ça c'est très
mauvais pour avec votre teint quoi
qu'est ce qui t'a pas mais avoue je suis
certain vous faites du xviii très sinon
un bon 20 15 complètement zinzin quoi il
parle
mais attention vous êtes hyper tendu
vous n'avez jamais de bourdonnements
d'oreille ça suffit connard ah oui vous
le pouvez 20 ça suffit comme ça
bon c'est à qui le tour de les garder
[Applaudissements]
et a fait mal c'est un jeu crâne comme
ça mais j'ai une de ses fruits si tu
crois que tu es le sol
[Applaudissements]
et j'en ferai statut lourd même même
celles motion sur le quai les bonnes
vaches d'hérens place par toi connard
je n'aime pas ce mec qui me fait peur
dans un coup comme cfa pour les enfants
de choeur dis moi je monte au nez qui
coule au tchad dans la brousse les
emmena toujours comme ça en hélico moi
ce serait la première fois ils voient
comment g dans ses environs est attendu
dans les salles d'arcade dakar on voit
si on a arrêté
vidéo
j'ai boire avec moi
tiens oui
1 et ligoté les faux billets banjul
de vrais billets pour demain
la 33 47
le trois facultés tirs
à quelle heure il passe
3h40 sais je sais
et qu'est-ce que marmonner là bas
non
[Musique]
les piliers
à
tél
[Musique]
les pieds
plus un
le train
m
[Musique]
plus il dit
j'ai dit silence
comprenez le français
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
et
e
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les allées lui donnez moi ça
[Musique]
alors on verra
elle
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas de casa premièrement c'est ça
j'espère qu'ils n'avaient pas payé sa
chair pourquoi
mon pauvre ami vous allez avoir des
surprises
ne pensez pas au fer chaud regardez-moi
ça au moins 80% de viscose j'espère
qu'on voulait pas donner pour des
moutons et sans l'étiquette dans le
coffre une édition qu'une indication
vous savez que vous pouvez porter
plainte le fabricant doit marquer
clairement la composition du tissu et la
température de lavage
or moi votre place je pour très bientôt
ça va pas les déranger concis peu dit
monsieur vous connaissez la sphère du
fou qui se prenait pour un naze amène
alors on attend meneuse pour ceux qui
n'en ont l'air de fou et puis il ya
trois ans après des guerriers le médecin
chef de l'hôpital et sahraoui pour la
faire boire peu
[Applaudissements]
et veut
tu abuses toutes les russies
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
longueur de jour en jour
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas
il veut la loi
il
[Musique]
et quand il s'était piqué et parle non
une écharde sans doute
[Applaudissements]
claudine vous a dit qu'on a choisi le
papier peint pour nouvel appartement
qu'est-ce que vous avez m l'uni
ambassades épandre dans la cuisine des
des fleurs jaunes et oranges sur fond
des français enfin pas beige marron
marron clair non tabac non si tabac bon
si tu veux c'est pas si je veux si le
terme exact tabac vous avez vérifié la
qualité du papier peint un oui du
lavables la bague de la cuisine vous
devez steve hâbler presse est pas la
même chose
pas du tout j'ai la norme à la maison
c'est prévoir des 0 bah quoi vous jouez
cause et vous causer des vauréens partir
de maintenant plus personne ne parle
c'est non
étant attendus ce qu'on vient de te dire
je voudrais les toilettes
or même le
est ce que vous avez j'emmène peas et
joël plugs prochaine v6 comme vous et
moi les calmerait laissait pas filer bon
dieu nous tuer à l'agencé ria appelle le
lattois il obéira ce n'est pas sûr ne
discute pas ap le lait en dhr léandre
plus fortes hausses à bon dieu les indre
léandre d'un chien s'est taillé j'espère
qu'il ne va pas se perdre
non mais tu te fous de ma gueule non
j'ai fait le choix de le faire filer a
pas d'annoncé vous si vous ne l'aviez
pas donné un coup de pied
moi c'est de salade je veux savoir
pourquoi vous avez fait ça je n'en
voyais pas venir quelqu'un bien sûr
quelqu'un qui par le chien
ce
[Musique]
où
vous
[Musique]
quelle heure est il
j'ai vraiment aller
claudine
on a dit à la baby sitter qu on serait
rentrés avant une heure du nord
[Musique]
je vais m'en aller c'est pas du disque
l'osce a entendu mon bébé
[Applaudissements]
car je voulais être parler je t'écoute
il comprend rien non mais
du moins coûteux récolte ce qu attend en
garde 60 et que tous les affreux ouais
c'était quoi le même boulot kissin ou
savoir sur convertir mon vieux toi aussi
tu étais dans l'armée non qu'est ce que
tu vas faire de ton pognon je me tire au
canada et là j'achète une ferme a eu du
pt qui est marrant à devoir on croirait
fera faux par les cinq minutes
je
ben alors
bien
à la cuisse tu fais là
tu as l'air pur mais toi
aux habitudes
là
tous habitent et moi ça
à voir
avec sauvage des patrons ils s'en
foutent que tu sois domaine
dis moi ça
peut-être que là dedans
un massacre est tout petit
il faut des lunettes
en même qui a des trous dedans
à
sos otages garbe les hold up 3 h 47
hélico à bas
il y en a qui savent pas quoi faire pour
rigoler en otage
mme lepage
comme si en france ces conneries exister
bah
ce serait vrai qu'on n'y croirais pas
je prends ta place tu as causé
ftq louis maurice et à un truc auquel on
n'a pas pensé
le patron a dit qu'on avait quatre
minutes pour détacher wagon l'arrimer à
l'hélico et grimper dedans
ces jeunes on peut y arriver siècle nous
et si en plus il faut charger les deux
bonnes femmes
mais quoi ça prendra une ou deux mille
de plus tu sais comment c'est fait qu'un
hélico et en plus ils résisteront c'est
un bon quart d'heure qu'il faudra au
bout d'un quart d'heure on va voir ce
que les filles du coin sous le paletot
la conclusion faut les supprimer avant
le coup on va quoi que cinq personnes
et comme au fleix enfin c'est toi même
si de l'avis pas de ça ce sont les
ordres du patron alors qu'à donner son
numéro de téléphone
oui c'est vrai d'accord on y va
le poids de pièces
[Musique]
dites moi vous n'auriez pas les pièces
deux enfants des fois oui c'est pour le
taxiphone on voulait rendre à
merci merci beaucoup
il va rappeler dans dix minutes
qu'est ce tu fais la débrouille minable
je t'emmerde
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
la marque sur le quai
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
on
verges
alors oui oui c'est michel et tous le
chef de gare aussi quand ok d'accord
tiens genre alors quand le wagon sera
arrimée à l'hélico juste avant qu'on
monte à bord non je ne marche pas c'est
un ordre et 1,15 d'accord d'accord
le salon c'est un ordre du patron
cheveux cos
je suis plus dans le coup
tu veux vraiment nous quitter dégonflé
d'accord j'ai rien dis tu l'auras ta
ferme canada
[Musique]
tu n'es pas
c'est un drôle d'anniversaire de mariage
[Musique]
en fait
j'aimerais que les données après le
dîner et tout ça j'ai oublié
[Musique]
il
content
c'est quelque chose
[Musique]
quand arrivera tenté et
m
[Musique]
je fais ça se voit
dans l'action
aussi souvent jeu
[Musique]
c
auxerre fait quoi
batum le train est dit qu un truc
[Musique]
pourquoi tu as vu que ça marchait fort
je pense pas trop
[Musique]
allez je trouve
elle est toutefois tout ça
[Musique]
il
ce sera bientôt fini
[Musique]
et non
avec le pôle erp regarde criminelle
c'est orient
[Musique]
avant
par candice heck
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
et
deux minutes
[Musique]
faire alors
le joueur
banimmo et
[Musique]
et
ça y est à bagnols
alors qu'est ce qu'ils valent et moi moi
attendant vous accrocher les wagons
tiens voilà c'est une avance de deux
minutes 15
l'alcool
ah bon quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des soldats machine
pas du tout
wait see
mais
m
[Musique]
à tenir ona
ici le commandant d'alsace de la
gendarmerie nationale gérer vos otages
la gare est cerné en et vous n'avez
aucune chance je répète vous n'avez
aucune chance en émaux
à
mon bon monsieur et madame lafarge je
suppose commandant d'alsace enchanté
voulu élever une fière chandelle 1 celui
remarqué au début nous n'y avons pas
tellement cru le message de détresse
ça paraissait un peu rocambolesque non
plus que c'est un clochard qui nous a
alertés ils avaient brûlé votre papier
il a eu des remords à tout hasard nous
avons envoyé deux gendarmes ont inspecté
la gare oui nous les avons entendus mais
ils sont partis aussitôt il en savait
assez nous avions été avisés de la mise
en circulation du train et nous savions
que la sncf avait demandé à ses agents
d'assurer la surveillance générale des
gares monsieur brochand le chef de garde
auraient dû être là or la gare était
fermé c'était le signe qu'il y avait
quelque chose d'anormal on aurait pu
donner l'assaut mais c'était beaucoup
trop dangereux pour vous voilà alors
nous avons organisé rapidement cette
opération en catastrophe pour prendre
les malfaiteurs de vitesse voilà et tout
ça grâce à toi mon vieux des enfants dit
dit commandant ya une chose que je ne
comprends pas comment avez vous fait
pour intercepter leur hélicoptère en
étant plus rapide que oui il était
évident que il ne pouvait arriver avant
le train enfin
un peu plus tôt 10 heures une demi
minute minutes juste le temps de
décrocher le wagon c'est pourquoi notre
hélicoptère est arrivé 2 minutes 30
secondes avant le train alors lorsque le
leur est arrivé bien il a vu que la
place était prise pilote a compris que
le coup était ratée alors il a voulu
rebrousser chemin mais à nos avions l'a
pris en chasse et l'a obligé à se poser
sur un champ voilà donc deux et eric
deux hélicoptères un avion ça représente
combien de litres de kérosène tout ça
excusez moi madame mais là il faudrait
demander à un spécialiste
oui bon je ne voudrais pas avoir l'air
de vous faire des reproches commandant
d'autant plus que vous nous avez sauvé
la vie mais quand on pense au nombre de
mètres cubes d'air ainsi polluer sans
compter le bruit plus de 100 décibels
certainement c'était difficilement
supportable je vous assure
ma femme fait partie d'une ligue que de
consommateurs
confidence pour confidence monsieur
lafarge la mienne aussi
or
c'est pas tout ça il faut que j'avance
tu viens décernés
c'est universal de valérie les enfants
scandale samedi lynn c'est une [ __ ] je
suis de permanence vient de recevoir la
dépêche
[Rires]
[Musique]